sackboy a big adventure has absolutely
blown
me away from the gameplay to the
collectibles to the level design and yes
britney spears
believe it or not that's not the only
bit of licensed music you'll instantly
recognize
in this game seriously it is full of so
many
surprises starting with the fact that
it's legit amazing
so today we're going to review sackboy
of big adventure and share a few more of
the surprises in store for you with this
title
but not too many after all you don't
want to spoil everything let's get into
it
people of the internet retro wrecking
tour here if we're meeting for the first
time i'm just a dad who loves games and
the stories they tell
we post videos every week here on
youtube and also stream over on twitch
when i put zac boy a big adventure on my
2020 christmas list i'll be honest
it was mainly a game i added so i could
have something new for my six-year-old
son and i to play together on our new
ps5
he loved astros playroom which i have a
breakdown up here on my channel
but we wanted something we could enjoy
together well little did i know that
dear old dad here would actually be
gifted one of the
best platformers i've seen in years
seriously guys we're talking nintendo
and
mario level quality here now if you've
played the old little big planet games
you're probably thinking yeah
okay well i played those two and to be
honest while they were cute with lots of
creativity i never found the gameplay to
be all that fun or innovative really the
controls were clunky the gameplay was
decent but when most folks think of
littlebigplanet they likely think of the
many
fan created levels rather than the
actual gameplay itself
that goes completely out the window with
sac boy a big adventure which was
released
alongside the ps5 back in november it's
also available on ps4 however but what's
so great about it for starters this is
not just
another little big planet game with a
new title slapped on this is a 3d
platformer developed by sumo digital and
not
media molecule the original creators of
the series true
i appreciate media molecule and what
they did in terms of customization
co-op and level creation with the
original games but sackboy a big
adventure is the best
game so far in the series and it's so
different right away you'll notice how
well sackboy controls especially
compared to the floatiness of the
original games
here sacboy's movement is responsive and
tight he can run
jump punch grab roll and do this little
extra floaty jump
thing basically it helps him cross
larger gaps the game is divided up into
a series of hub worlds and while it's
described as a 3d platformer there are a
number of different ways sumo switches
up the perspective throughout the game
with tweaks to level design along the
way
it does operate from a fixed perspective
which kind of gives it the feel of
something like super mario 3d world
95 of the time the camera is rock solid
there are a couple of times where the
perspective is a little bit off and it
makes it hard to judge
distance between two platforms for
example but this is incredibly rare
sac boy does a phenomenal job with
pacing steadily introducing new
mechanics as you go and then finding new
ways to alter those mechanics so the
gameplay never grows stale
most of the footage you see here is from
the game's earliest levels but as you
get further into the game you'll find
special mechanics or unique items that
you'll only use during a specific level
or even a specific section of a level
i'm not going to spoil them all here but
i will tease that you'll be doing a lot
more than just running
jumping and punching and not in a
gimmicky way either it completely feels
natural here in sacboy which is made
possible by the game's outstanding level
design you'll find plenty of familiar
platforming mechanics but there are
definitely some unique twists here as
well
each level has a plethora of different
collectibles to find
and challenges to complete there are
also hundreds of different costume
pieces for your sack person some of
which
are found hidden throughout the levels
and others that you can purchase with
gold you collect
in-game you certainly won't be making
your own levels or having the wide range
of customization that we saw in the
littlebigplanet games
but you will have a variety of different
cosmetics to unlock that will
alter the appearance of your sack person
there are different hair styles
helmets glasses shirts pants emotes
facial expressions and even different
fabrics for the sack person underneath
it all sacboy strikes that perfect
balance of presenting just enough of a
challenge to be difficult but not too
frustrating for inexperienced gamers to
lose interest
there are also plenty of ways for
hardcore gamers to challenge themselves
with the game's time
trial levels and many hidden
collectibles although you can play
sackboy solo the game shines brightest
when you play alongside a friend or even
a group of friends as a total of four
players can team up
online play certainly is supported here
but my son and i have had an
absolute blast giving it the old couch
co-op experience
i should also note here that the game
does indeed support cross play between
ps4 and ps5 so if you have friends say
who are on a different system from you
it's nice to know you can still play
together
okay now let's talk about that music i
did not expect
licensed music to be in this game like
at all guys i have no idea maybe they
announced this beforehand maybe this was
a well-known thing but for me it came as
a total surprise when certain hit songs
started playing
out of nowhere i gave you one already
but honestly i don't want to spoil the
rest of them if you really want to know
though i am going to include the
official spotify playlist
in the description below so you can
check that out if you really really
really want to know the songs what's
crazy is it's not just
about the music guys it's not just kind
of playing in the background the level
itself actually reacts to the beat and
there are even moments where it has a
direct
impact on the gameplay for example the
timing of the beat could be the exact
moment you need to jump to another
platform or when you need to be ready
for an enemy to attack
if you can't tell already from the
footage here the graphics and art style
are phenomenal
the game's style in particular helps
feed into the overall charm with lively
worlds filled with obstacles enemies and
interactive objects that are all
pleasing to the eye
keep in mind this is footage all running
on a ps5 at a rock solid 60 fps
for more detailed overview of the game's
performance you should check out digital
foundry's breakdown of the game which
i've also linked
in the description there are boss fights
throughout the game as well which will
usually test your ability to use
recently introduced gameplay mechanics
or special items you've obtained i don't
read as many video game reviews as i
used to and while i had heard a few
rumblings that sackboy was better than
expected i have to say it has completely
exceeded my expectations the main story
can be beaten probably in around 10
hours but if you're looking for all the
collectibles doing the co-op levels
testing your platforming skills with the
time trials you could easily spend 25 to
30 hours here
so is there anyone i wouldn't recommend
sackboy to i think that's a more valid
question guys the only people i could
think of are those who maybe don't enjoy
platformers and prefer to play alone at
all times if you're a fan of platformers
but prefer solo i do think sackboy is
still worth your while
just know that you won't be able to
experience all the game has to offer by
going it
only alone i give sackboy a big
adventure a
big thumbs up and recommend it to anyone
who enjoys platformers or wants
something fun and lighthearted to play
with family and friends
now if any of you out there have kids
little brothers little sisters who
you want to play this game alongside i
cannot recommend it enough it has been
so incredibly fun to play this alongside
my son
we have laughed so many times because
the game just sets itself up so well for
these hilarious moments where
you may fail but you just have to laugh
at yourself because of it and it also
gives you plenty of opportunities to
like help out the other person so
there's a lot of teamwork involved
and then one of my favorite things is at
the end of each level it'll show you who
got the high score for that level and
you're presented with a trophy
but if the other character runs up and
hits you they can actually take the
trophy from you
of course my six-year-old just cackles
maniacally when he does this he loves it
honestly he's played and enjoyed
a lot of games so far the past couple
years especially throughout the pandemic
he really enjoyed animal crossing he
really enjoyed super mario odyssey
i would certainly put this one right up
there with those three that's how much
we've enjoyed it together
if you found this video helpful please
consider giving it a like and if you
want to stick around and be part of the
community here then consider subscribing
to the channel where we post videos
every week
as always thank you all so much for
watching i'll talk to you again soon